hall-of-fame boxing analyst al Bernstein
right here good to see you sir great to
be with you again I love that's that
music just it is it's stirring isn't it
it's like embedded in our psyche and
when we hear it it gives you instant
memories of what we're how you saw it
you know what I think of when I thought
of people think of the rocky steps and
all that hmm do you have the beginning
the first the first song of the music
have have it ready it's it's such an
assign oh you're big pop culture guy -
when rah spoiler alert in the first
rocky which is the best rocky I don't
want to hear anything else okay none of
the other Rocky's were in the hunt to
use the football phrase for an Oscar
that's true would you agree yeah I agree
best rocky even number one okay though I
was in number five and I did add
expedition but rocky number one is the
best without you rocky five wouldn't
have been here I felt I carried the
movie form I know but when rocky didn't
you know wasn't gonna fight because
Adrian him it was a love story at age
you didn't want him to get hurt right
and he wanted to do right by his love
coz Rocky's a love story it's not
essentially a movie it's a love story
point others told us this you did when
he was on this show when she asked him
you know what you know what he basically
says what's up but she says let me tell
you something he leans over and she just
says win yeah and that's when this music
plays I'm getting goose bumps into the
rich ii - yes and - because she's in bed
for she adrian tells rocky he can't win
yeah which makes him go to Russia to
train even harder and then she shows up
and then he wins Drago she's better than
The Godfather
we don't we live in a time where facts
don't matter so no worries
it doesn't matter it's a mitt I thought
that was rocky one like him too ah when
then I hear that music Rocky one was an
extraordinary move it was has anybody
ever in you're the perfect person ask
this is the whole thing boxing has
anybody ever eaten lightning and crap
thunder in real life birds do not to the
best of my knowledge but I'll tell you
what I'm gonna investigate that for you
and welcome to the next time I'm back on
I'll give you a full report on it is
that what Wilder was telling fury at the
the way and that went a little sideways
that's what he's eating and crapping
yeah so that was their colorful this was
something else this way and well give me
the last heavyweight fight that you
think has had this sort of buzz this
sort of in the United States the last
one that that was Lois Lennox Lewis and
Mike Tyson in the United States that's
been a long yeah and yeah and and you
know boxing while it's had a bit of a
renaissance in the last four or five
years the heavyweight division has not
gotten involved in that and in America
we like big things right
we like heavyweights trunks the truck
power buildings anything that's large we
like so we like heavyweights and the the
heavyweight division has begun to really
you know create some excitement and some
interest in the last couple years and so
this is kind of a lot in the next
logical extension of that with Tyson
Fury coming over from across the pond a
fighter that the casual boxing fan knows
who he is because he beat Vladimir
Klitschko for the lineal title in front
of like a hundred thousand people right
yes and and with this plus all the
excitement that Anton Joshua is creating
I was there for we were there to do his
several of his fights in front of 90,000
people in Wembley Stadium that's
extraordinary
um it's created stirring and a
heavyweight division so this one they
are hoping number one it helps put
Deontay Wilder on the map to the casual
boxing fan and helps the sport that's
why you think this is caught some
eyeballs and buzz that the heavyweight
division is not in quite some time
yeah
I think this kind of is part of the
reawakening of the heavyweight division
you know the ante Walter had a great
fight earlier this past year against
Luis Ortiz at the Barclays center they
filled up the Barclays Center
essentially we had well over a million
viewers on on Showtime and it was a
really important fight and exciting
Deontay Wilder tested in that fight
almost out on his feet but came back to
win that was kind of the the the setup
the hors d'oeuvre if you will is this
which they're hoping will be playing out
on an international stage how Bernstein
here on the Rich Eisen show so play out
for me how you see this one going it's
interesting you know that the
conventional wisdom is that Deontay
Wilder will who has huge power in his
right hand is an unconventional fighter
but when he lands that right hand Wow
you know people go down he'll be looking
to land that punch and land power
punches Tyson Fury who is coming back
off you know it was only a two fight
since his long layoff due to mental
illness and drug problems he's hoping to
decompress every round make win round by
round and at the end of the day get his
hand raised with 12-round decision 6
foot 9 257 pounds and by the way it's
absurd yeah and by the way he's the only
the first fighter that Wilder's fought
who's taller than Wilder who's 7 yeah so
that's an interesting it that's a stat
that I think could play an important
role in this fight plus they're in their
30s so these are grown-ass men yeah
exactly - yeah and and you know it's
fascinating and and the part about in
this you know we have these two men very
different in you from different places
in the world both without size
personalities but the different styles
in the ring so it kind of creates this I
think an interesting kind of tension for
this fight interesting and you said Luis
Tyson that's the last topic in America
in America in America yeah probably the
last one that created this kind of this
kind of interest what's exciting that
out the heavyweight division might be
having some sort of young awakening I
mean are there others that are coming up
through the system if you will based on
these two guys maybe leading the way or
yeah I think you know there's there's
some other heavyweight prospects again
most of them European and British but
why is that you know the theory goes
that most of that people that would be
heavyweight boxers now are either tight
ends or power forwards I mean that's the
mind's eye on Williamson these are the
numbers that we write and wait that
we're seeing from this exactly and and
the theory is that's what they've done
going into those sports because in the
lower weight division boxing does not
have a dearth of talent you know there
are gyms all over America are producing
superb fighters in every other weight
division so in London there are no tight
ends or power-forward precisely and so
for their football that's my story and
I'm sticking to it rich well I mean it
kind of does but the way it is it's a
simplistic viewpoint but but it is part
of the story al Bernstein here on the
Rich Eisen show what else you up to sir
what else do I need to know about your
life well we're gonna have of course our
next Showtime event will be on January
19th another pay-per-view will be Manny
Pacquiao and Adrien Broner the shy and
retiring Adrien Broner coming back to
the ring
and what does Pacquiao have left he you
know he fought very well in his last
fight against Lucas Matisse a part of
that was Matisse a not fighting well but
back has essentially had one bad fight
he you know so he feels like he at age
forty he still has something to offer
and his fight with brother he's actually
gonna go in the favorite in that fight
but it should be a very interesting
entertaining fight are we ever gonna see
Pacquiao and Mayweather coming in the
rings on Rascals and just start beating
each other or something like that is
that you see the fight will be when they
come back again the fight will be
sponsored by AARP will be yep well so
it'll be a cocoon marathon will show the
videos doing the promotion for that yeah
you know diabetes see that being on your
show is great because you're not getting
that anywhere else you're not get a
chance
there's no Jessica Tandy rough or not
they're gonna be
anywhere else you're trying to promote
Tyson Fury and Deontay Wilder no you do
not get a chance to mention her Wilford
Brimley or Jim amici was he not heard on
of autonomy an amici
well we already made a Duke brothers
reference okay and the night before the
Pacquiao burner frightened you have an
open invitation to come and be a guest
singer I'm gonna do my music show at the
Tuscany Hotel in Las Vegas on and you
have an open invitation to come and
Kenny Davidson who who runs the band
there he's the biggest Rich Eisen fan on
the planet and he even open invitation
to come and sing now what date is this
five that is it's on the 19th so I know
your NFL duties make this a championship
Sunday shows on a Friday night so if you
could get back to LA well I there's a
jock if you don't mind me worth talk to
sound my schedule through that Friday
we've got a Rich Eisen shows perfect
okay and then I've got an NFL gameday
morning meeting for championship Sunday
which is a six-hour show and the meeting
usually is like a nice three hours but
that's not usually until 2 o'clock in
the afternoon I do see a window of
opportunity here al if you could get one
so I'd fly we'd flying to Vegas that's a
that the Royal ways it's we all
collectively we're all there right yeah
okay but I'm the only one invited to get
up on the stage but you all can come
look we'll have a special table table
arrange for you guys okay
like Goodfellas they just pull it out
and we'll be able to get a drink at the
table right because you know drinks
waited because freighters run around or
on the house not around
okay there you know you can't get drinks
at the table from what I heard okay so
you plugged in so it would be that's
life that Sinatra and that is a I'm just
letting you know that's usually a
showstopper I just want to let you know
I sing and you're short I want to end
I want to tell rearrange your setlist I
won't follow though I'll have some other
portion of follow you I don't know
enough not to do that I'll introduce you
but I won't follow you Roy Firestone why
should we throw another sportscaster
under the under the bus no you have an
open invitation to this and it will be
John Castle media sue writes the
entertainment common in the review
journal has shown me John I used to I
used to be around with John exactly for
the reading record search that's right
tell me that he will he's gonna he'll
write a special thing about that so so
this is all gonna be a big thing they
back machine Hotel & Casino
yes hotel how do I not play the Tuscany
Hotel and Casino you have to do it be
great shut it down okay we're gonna pull
out all the stops to make this man want
to overshadow the fight though you know
who'd do that you know what thank you on
behalf of all the Showtime executives
that are my bosses I think they'll risk
that well maybe we could do a
behind-the-scenes show times gotta have
let's do one of those well access in all
access I like it Rich Eisen al Bernstein
Tuscany Hotel and Casino all access by
the way we have hatched quite the caper
you know we have this is gonna be a fun
fight man check it out on Showtime and
you could the pay-per-view check it out
right now that's what people can go to
right yeah pay-per-view Showtime papers
you to see fury and Wilder and should be
fine and Jared heard who's the 154 punch
ampion coming back off an injury he's
one of the most exciting fighters in
boxing fighting Jason Wellborn who's a
very exciting fighter from England and
Jared heard coming that was in fight of
the year against Erislandy Lara he's
always an exciting fight so that's one
should be a good one underneath live on
Showtime pay-per-view
go ahead ask him a question you just got
in my ear go for it I know you said fury
is hoping for a 12-round decision but do
you see this fight going the distance it
well it
Tyson Kruger would like it to go 12 and
the question is does he what the two
fights back against very mediocre
opposition was that enough for Tyson
Fury to get himself back to fight with
Deontay Wilder the wilder folks and
Wilder is the favorite and fight would
tell you the fights gonna end earlier
now don't discount the idea Tyson Fury
is gonna try and make Wilder fall into
traps he'll try and make him overextend
try and make him do things rush things
lunge and Tyson Fury has some pop in
this punch so we have seen Wilder get
shook up whereas he was against Luis
Ortiz right don't rule out the
possibility that Fury could hurt him now
that was an excellent question that
yielded a well postulated nuanced
response from Hall of Fame boxing
analyst al Bernstein del 2 foe can you
get that rocky theme ready again I think
we could produce this a little bit
better
Mike don't when I when I point at you
you hit like okay ask the question again
al what is it possible I know Tyson Fury
wants this to go 12 rounds do you think
this fight does go 12 rounds
Tyson sure you would like this to go 12
rounds and wants it to go four rounds
needs it to go 12 rounds but Wilder
wants to end it early with one of those
powerful right hands don't you think
that was a little bit better I mean no
offense would you like was that better
with the produce more dramatic and I
made my response more dramatic notice
cuz I want to work with you January 18th
at the Tuscany Hotel oh my gosh it's
gonna be an epic night and how many
piece band is there behind you 3 piece
but we'll also have a I was always get a
saxophonist
Rob stone who's the best satyrs
saxophone player in Las Vegas will be
backing us as well and he'll accent your
song extreme that song cries out for
saxophone and he will
accentuated very well and you'll be
thrilled that you're my play with you
that's life
yes oh my gosh in the meantime check out
hold on minute let me let me think about
it here we go
let me think about it you got you got
that song one more time Mike here let me
just something else I'm pondering about
it hold on a minute let me think about
it should I do it should I not do it I
have no idea
Mike del twofolds already set it up can
you do it give me okay you know what
Rich Eisen I've got NFL game day morning
championship Sunday it's a huge show
it's ours named Sunday and Casino but
the meeting the show meetings not till 2
o'clock the next day this by the way is
this wasn't in any of the Rockies no but
that Friday night I can get on stage
with al Bernstein at the Tuscany Hotel
and Casino and Rob stone offset on the
sax and get up there and Mike drop
that's life to an unsuspecting Las Vegas
Nevada audience how do I not do it you
have to I'm gonna go up on that stage
and take that Sinatra microphone and eat
like being in cracks under thanks for
coming on now out Bernstein everybody
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience